my name is Rebecca and I'm a cyber work
specifically I have 32 computer chips
inside my head which rebuild my sense of
hearing this is called a cochlear
implant you remember the the Borg from
Star Trek those aliens who conquered and
absorb everything inside well that's me
the good news is I come for your
technology and not fear human life-forms
actually I've never seen an episode of
Star Trek but there's a reason for that
television wasn't closed-captioned when
I was a kid I grew up profoundly deaf I
went to regular schools and I had to lip
read I didn't meet another deaf person
until I was 20 electronics were mostly
audio back then my alarm clock was my
sister Barbra who would set her alarm
and then throw something at me to wake
up my hearing aids were
industrial-strength sledgehammer volume
but they helped me more than they helped
most people with them I could hear music
and the sound of my own voice I've
always liked the idea that technology
can help make the world more human I
used to watch the stereo flash color
when the music shifted and I knew it was
just a matter of time before my watch
could show me sound too did you know
that hearing occurs in the brain in your
ear is a small organ called the cochlea
and the cochlea is lined with thousands
of receptors called hair cells when
sound enters your ear those hair cells
they send electrical signals to your
brain and your brain then interprets
that as sound
hair cell damage is really common noise
exposure ordinary aging illness my hair
cells were damaged before I was even
born my mother was exposed to German
measles when she was pregnant with me
about 5% of the world has significant
hearing loss by 2050 that's expected to
double to over 900 million people or one
in ten for seniors it's already one out
of three with a cochlear implant
computer chips do the job for the
damaged hair cells imagine a box of 16
crayons and those 16 crayons in
combination have to make all of the
colors in the universe same with the
cochlear implant I have 16 electrodes in
each of my cochlea those 16 electrodes
in combination sends signals to my brain
representing all of the songs in the
universe I have electronics inside and
outside of my head to make that happen
including small processor magnets inside
my skull and a rechargeable power source
radio waves transmit sound through the
magnets the number one question that I
got about the cochlear implant when
people hear about the magnets is whether
my head sticks to the refrigerator
no it says not I know this because I
tried hearing people assume that the
Duff live in it in a perpetual state of
wanting to hear because I can't imagine
any other way but I've never once wish
to be hearing I just wanted to be part
of a community like me I wanted everyone
else to be dass I think that sense of
belonging is what ultimately connects
our stories and might felt incomplete
when cochlear implants first got going
back in the 80s
the operation was Frankenstein monster
scary by 2001 the procedure had evolved
considerably but it still wiped out any
natural hearing that you had the success
rate then for speech comprehension was
low maybe 50% so if it didn't work you
couldn't go back at that time implants
were also controversial in the deaf
culture basically it was considered the
equivalent of changing the color of your
skin I held off for a while but my
earring was going downhill fast and
hearing aids were no longer helping so
in 2003 I made the tough decision to
have the cochlear implant I just needed
to stop that soul-sucking cycle of loss
regardless of whether the operation
worked and I really didn't think that it
would I saw it as one last box to check
off before I made the transition to
being completely deaf which a part of me
wanted complete silence is very
addictive
maybe you've spent time in a sensory
deprivation tank and you know what I
mean
silence has mind-expanding capabilities
in silence I see sound
when I watch a music video without sound
I can hear music in the absence of sound
my brain fills in the gaps based on the
movement I see my mind is no longer
competing with the destruction of sound
its freed up to think more creatively
there are advantages to having bionic
body parts as well it's undeniably
convenient to be able to hear and I can
turn it off anytime I've lived I'm
hearing when I need to be and the rest
of the time I'm not bionic hearing
doesn't age although external parts
sometimes need replacement it would be
so cool to just automatically regenerate
a damaged part like a real cyborg but I
get mine FedEx from Advanced Bionics oh
I get updates downloaded into my head
it's not quite airdrop a book close with
the cochlear implant I can stream music
from my ipod into my head without
earbuds recently I went to a friend's
long tedious concert and unknown to
anyone else
I listened to the Beatles for three
hours instead
technology has come so far so fast the
biggest obstacle I faced as a deaf
person is no longer a physical barrier
it's the the way that people respond to
my deafness the outdated way people
respond to my deafness pity
patronization even anger because that
just cancels out the human connection
the technology achieves I once had a
travel roommate who had a complete
temper tantrum because I didn't hear a
knocking on the door when her key didn't
work if I hadn't been there no problem
she could get another key but when she
saw that I was there her anger boiled
over she it was no longer about a key it
was about deafness not being a good
enough reason for her inconvenience or
the commercial about the deaf man whose
neighbourhood surprised him with sign
language messages from people on the
street everyone who sent me the video
told me they cried so I asked them well
what if he wasn't gasps what if his
first language was Spanish and everyone
learnt Spanish instead would you have
cried and they all said no they weren't
crying because of the communication
barrier they were crying because the man
was deaf but I see it differently what
if the Borg showed up in that video and
the bork said toughness is irrelevant
because that's what they say right
everything's are relevant and then the
Borg assimilated the dust guy not out of
pity not out of anger but because he had
a biological distinctiveness that the
Borg wanted including unique language
capabilities I would much rather see
that commercial
why does thinking about ability make
people so uncomfortable you might know a
play later a movie called children of a
lesser God by Mark met off
that play that title actually comes from
a poem by Alfred Tennyson and I
interpret the both the play and title to
say that humans who are perceived as
defective were made by a lesser God and
live in inferior existence while those
made by the real God are a superior
class because God doesn't make mistakes
in World War Qiu an estimated two
hundred and seventy-five thousand people
with disabilities were murdered in
special death camps because they didn't
fit Hitler's vision of a superior race
Hitler said that he was inspired by the
United States which had enacted
involuntary sterilization laws for the
unfed in the early 1900s that practice
continued in more than 30 states until
the seven years with the last law
finally repealed in 2003 so the world is
not that far removed from Tennyson's
poem that tendency to make assumptions
about people based on ability comes out
in sentences like you're so special I
couldn't live like that or thank God
that's on me changing how people think
is like getting them to break a habit
before the implant I had stopped using
the voice telephone and switched to
email but people kept leaving me
voicemail they were upset that I wasn't
reachable by phone and not returning
messages I continued to tell them my
situation it took them months to adapt
fast-forward 10 years and you know who
else hated voice mail Millennials
and you know what they did they
normalize texting for communication
instead now when it comes to ignoring
voicemail it no longer matters whether
you're deaf or just self-absorbed
Millennials changed how people think
about messaging they reset the default
can I just tell you how much I love
texting oh and group tax my I have six
siblings they're all hearing but but I
don't think any less of them and we all
text do you know how thrilling it is to
have a visual means of communication
that everyone else actually uses so I am
on a mission now as a consumer of
technology I want visual options
whenever there's audio it doesn't matter
whether I'm deaf or don't want to wake
the baby both are equally valid smart
designers include multiple ways to
access technology but segregating that
access under accessibility that's just
hiding it from mainstream users in order
to change how people think we need to be
more than accessible we need to be
connected Apple did this recently on my
iPhone it automatically displays a
visual transcript of my voicemail right
next to the audio button I couldn't turn
it off even if I wanted to you know what
else
Netflix Hulu Amazon Prime no longer stay
close caption for the hearing impaired
they say subtitles on or off with a list
of languages underneath including
English technology has come so far our
mindset just needs to catch up
resistance is futile
you have been assimilated thank you
[Applause]
[Music]